what do you know about twin primes brady
i know that they are
prime numbers
that are separated by two
is it proven they're an infinite number
of them or is that still no they haven't
got that twin prime conjecture the twin
frame conjecture is still called a
conjecture and james maynard talks about
that on number five regularly they've
got the gap down
but if they can get the gap to two to
prove that there is always going to be
another pair of twin primes no matter
how far you look then it'll be a big
deal in mathematics not because
necessarily that solves the world's
problems but it's a problem we don't
really know how to solve at the moment i
feel like i have an affinity with with
twin things i have a twin brother which
some number five viewers
may have heard about on a podcast but
let's explore a fact about twin primes
i'm not in james maynard territory here
i am a maths teacher not a
a grade mathematician but i i'd like to
try a little experiment i'm going to
write down a number which you can't see
i'm going to write it on the back of
this um
just to okay you're going to write it
there prediction yeah i can't see what
you're writing and i need you to grab a
calculator you could do this in your
head but i don't think you should okay
i'd like you to pick your favorite pair
of twin primes
put you on the spot now all right well i
can't go too high i'm gonna go i think i
think i've picked two that are prime
yeah where are you and i'd like you to i
mean i it doesn't matter if i see what
you're doing because i've made my
prediction right i can't guarantee okay
i'd like to find the product of those
two twin primes
17
times 19.
and then i'd like to find the digital
root of that by which i your face is
good so shame viewers can't see your
face brady the digital root is the a
technical name for add the digits
together
and if you don't get down to a single
digit you do it again
so digital sum repeated
all right so the digital root of that is
eight
really
you wanna just uh have a little
glimpse here
the number eight which i've carefully
written
yes i'm glad we're impressed by this
it's not a good magic trick but it is a
curious thing that i knew what was going
to happen
and did i know because i got lucky
and i think we should try the experiment
again 101 times 103. i feel like i
should be able to work this out but for
the sake of speed let's just trust the
electronics this is 10 403 and i add the
bits together the digits one and four
that's eight let's try another pair
uh i'm going to go and look up a pair of
twin primes i just found 6 17 and 6 19.
617
times
6
19
and add the digits we're going to get
26.
if we do it again
you guys don't
but i'm glad you chose a larger example
sometimes the digital it takes a couple
of steps to get down there sometimes it
takes a lot longer but it does look like
it's always gonna be eight and so that's
quite a nice fact if you believe it that
the product of any twin primes has a
digital root of eight
and for all the things we don't know
about primes and the things we don't
know about twin primes
do we know that that's true or is it
just a fluke in the first few examples
or do all primes do this like it like
like seven and eleven which aren't twin
primes
should we try i mean seventy-seven are
the digits
fourteen five so five is the counter
example
the brady conjecture was nice for a
moment but we found a counter example
actually a serious point like
mathematicians finding counter examples
to disprove things is just as important
right you reject the dross sorry to
insult your your conjecture so not all
prime products or primes do this
it's we check three examples but
obviously that's not enough so what i'd
like to do in this video is
prove it i'd like to prove it two
different ways
just to point that if something is true
there's not one way to prove something
and then proof becomes less about
getting the answer right and more about
a communication and that's it's
something which is a lot overlooked in
mathematics the stereotype of it being
right or wrong it's actually much more
about communicating well so we'll do two
proofs of the digital root of a product
to twin prime as being eight
proof one ready uh so i'm going to talk
about modular arithmetic here and
there's a it doesn't feel like there's
anything to do with this until you
recognize that almost any anything when
you talk about digital routes is to do
with thinking about modulo 9.
now you know about modular arithmetic
but just as a reminder is the way you if
i'm going to count in mod 9 i would
count up to 9 but 9 would be the same as
going back to the beginning and 0. and
so the number 10 mod 9 is 1 because it's
1 more than a multiple of nine and the
number 26
should have should have planned this
shouldn't it uh is let me guess uh it's
eight more than a multiple of nine
so it would be 26 equals eight mod nine
and the reason i'm doing that is anytime
you're talking about digital routes mod
9 comes into play for reasons which
we'll come to maybe as a bonus proof at
the end but if i think about things mod
9 i'm going to think about the prime
numbers mod 9 so just work with me here
the prime numbers as you know start with
two i'm not gonna get into the argument
about one and it's not important anyway
because actually when i was going to do
this trick i should have said to you can
you pick two twin primes
bigger than three
and i didn't say that because people
normally do
i i do need to say bigger than three and
that'll become obvious why uh have i got
these two three five seven eleven uh 13
let's go up a little bit further the
next one i think is 17 and then 19 and
then we've got to jump to
23. let's go with that so if i go mod 9
i'm looking for the remainder dividing
by 9. now the first few are
pretty easy even for me but this 11 just
help me out brady
mod like you said what nine what's left
over if you took away multiple of nine
two yeah i agree and so everyone else is
keeping up that's fine that's a four
this is almost up to the 18 so that's
going to be the highest you can get mod
9 and that's going to be one more than
mod 9 and that's going to be by
definition 4 more than that so it's got
to be five
do you have any comments about the the
list we're getting here and i'm actually
going to kind of separate these two
because they are the first
primes they're often special this is the
only even prime and that is the first
odd prime
beyond that
what's the next one going to be 29
and that's a 2. spoiler it doesn't
repeat
and maybe we'd be worried if it did
because uh the pattern of primes is
notoriously important and unpredictable
and the all sorts of riemann hypothesis
stuff is tied up with it so i'm gonna go
in there
but do you think we would ever get a
three in there
i'm guessing not but i'm just trying to
figure out why okay let's start with the
simple one will you ever get a zero
no because it will be a multiple of nine
right if you get a zero mod nine is a
multiple of nine and therefore
definitively not prime now nine has a
factor of three in it so
will you ever get a three will you ever
find a prime number which is three more
than a multiple of nine
no because it will be a multiple of
three yeah so three's out as well and
for the same reason six
and actually that's it we've seen the
others zero's not there one two uh
three's out four five six is out seven
eight that's all
so the first conclusion is you're never
gonna get zeros threes and sixes that
doesn't feel like it's rocket science uh
if you understand primes but it does
have a consequence because when we pick
a pair of twin primes
it means if we work in mod 9 we're only
going to get either
what do we say a 1
a 2
not a 3 a 4 a 5 not a 6 a 7 or an eight
those are the only
options we have mod nine
and a twin prime is going to have to be
two apart literally the definition of
twin primes so we've actually not got
many many options left what i'm gonna do
is kind of a proof by exhaustion i
couldn't do the original thing by
checking all cases but the nice thing
about working modular arithmetic is that
you quite often
turn it from a infinite list into a
finite list and then you can check
everything so
if i found a twin prime
that ended up two mod nine i'd need to
have the other twin
mod four so if you do two times four you
get eight mod nine the big step i
haven't commented on is that what is
mod9 got to do with digital roots well
everything and i want to save that for
the end but if i tell you now that the
digital root of a number is exactly the
same as it mod9
and we can prove that later if we need
to but that's it so i if i found uh two
twin primes that are two and four
multiplied they're going to get eight
mod nine which is the digital route so
the only option other option we could
have a
four matching with a six no we can't
have that we could have five matching
with seven
five times seven
uh 35
which goes
digital route to eight so that one's
working what else could we do with seven
we'd need to match with a nine but that
nine's not in the list eight would need
to match with a ten but ten is one mod
nine so we could have an and a one
and that is also eight
and that's it
whatever you do if you pick two twin
primes and multiply them together
you're gonna get an answer which is
eight mod nine which is the same as the
digital route and so it's a slight
observation i'm just saying if you
multiply two two and primes the way the
primes distribute themselves you're
always gonna get eight more nine and i
quite like it i do feel like i need to
see why mod 9 is is digital roots should
we do that now i feel like i want to say
it yeah okay let's do that now digital
route
is equivalent to mod 9 that's my claim
and i'm going to prove this in a way
that i
you could do more generally but for the
sake of notation i'm going to do an
example of a three-digit number um
if you imagine a three-digit number as a
b c it could be three to one could be
nine two six whatever i'm not treating
these as multiplying together vegeta's
representing the digits algebraically
that would be written as 100 lots of a
plus 10 lots of b plus c and i think
that's after a moment's thought if
that's not familiar it's not too
surprising because a hundred tens of
units are sort of a helpful thing now if
you want to upgrade this proof to do a
four-digit number you just have a
thousand of another letter at the front
and you could do this in general it's
just it gets notationally confusing and
i want to prove to be notationally not
confusing to get the sense of it and
then you can upgrade the formality later
on
so the digital root of this number abc
is
a plus b plus c
agreed
yep it's the three digits added together
maybe you do it again if it doesn't come
to a single digit but that's the step
you do so that's the sum of the digits
and now i'm going to work on the actual
algebraic version of the number to show
you that this that it's equivalent to
mod9 so 100a
it won't be surprising to you to learn
is the same as 99as plus a
and the catch here is you don't know why
i'm doing that and i've done something
similar with the 10b i turned it to 9b
plus b and the reason i've done that is
that i've got in this algebraic
expression i've got this a b and c which
is kind of what i'm aiming at over here
so if i rewrite this as 99 a's plus 9bs
plus abc you can see that the
the sum of the digits is in
the number itself
and what's left
is nine times something
and that's it
proof two uh we're trying to prove again
that twin primes the product of a twin
prime pair has a digital root of eight
imagine twin prime so i can imagine a
number n the next number is n plus one
and the number for it is n minus one i'm
going to claim that if you have a twin
prime they are going to be two apart
this is not representing its prime this
yet but i'm going to say if that is one
of your twin prime then that's the other
one it's instructive maybe to look at
the product of these two things all i'm
doing is checking the productive numbers
two apart at the moment so n minus one
times n plus 1.
so let me upgrade slightly i'm going to
say that in this list of three numbers
that we started with
uh certainly
one of them is going to be divisible by
three again it feels so obvious when you
realize why like but there's a list of
three numbers right so if that one's
divisible by three we're done if that
one's not divisible by three then either
this one is or this one is because this
is a list of three numbers
one in every three numbers is divisible
by exactly if they are primes
because they're twin primes they are not
divisible by three
agreed so this one is divisible by three
so i'm going to call it three k
we've sort of upgraded their information
if these are twin primes then this one
is a multiple of three guaranteed in
fact we've just proved by thinking that
every twin prime has a multiple of three
vary between them and it's not really
that surprising when you think about it
so if we upgrade then instead of using n
i'm gonna use three k then this
expression becomes slightly different
the product of the twin primes looks
like three k minus one multiplied by
three k plus one let's do some algebra
expanding brackets live on camera is
always dangerous this is going to be nk
squared minus one
uh so the product of twin primes is
going to look like that k is an integer
uh it's been multiplied by nine it's
been squared as well but i don't really
care about that tell me about this
mod9
it's negative one mod nine but we didn't
put that in an original list and
negative one is going backwards from
zero
so mod nine i could add nine and get
away with it i just wanted the eight to
appear in the digit so this equals eight
mod nine and that is it feels like a
really different proof to me we haven't
done a proof by exhaustion we haven't
gone to check the mod nines of all the
primes we just did an algebraic argument
identified that there was a multiple of
three and then the algebra tells us well
it's going to be 9k squared
plus 8.
and that's it i don't think this is a
great magic trick i know i've presented
it a bit like that but i like the idea
that
once you've got a fact which is always
true it feels like you can exploit it
and i'm not saying this is a useful fact
it's just a
curiosity about twin primes which we can
prove in several ways so first of all
that exists and i like it and secondly i
like reflecting as a mathematician on
which proof do you prefer
because there isn't a right proof and a
wrong proof there's a there's a proof
which works for you and there's proof
which works better for you or worse for
you
and i'm trying to redeem mathematics
from being this robotic thing to be a
human enterprise we're communicating
truth sounding very highfalutin but the
uh proof is important i think i liked
the second proof the algebraic one
yeah i think i because because i didn't
see it coming as obviously the algebra
just drops out suddenly whereas the
first one feels like it's a tedious
listing being improved by exhaustion
often feel like that proofs by
exhaustion are exhausting to check they
feel fiddly they feel like yeah you've
reduced it you've got to check them all
this feels like bam
this episode has been supported by
brilliant makers of fantastic courses
and puzzles like these that you can do
from the comfort of your computer or
tablet or your phone get smarter have
fun learning enjoy these super
interactive and lovingly designed
lessons everything about brilliance
created with care with the aim of
improving the way you think
this new everyday math course has some
great practical stuff in it if you
haven't signed up to brilliant yet you
don't know what you're missing and if
you have well why not consider brilliant
as a gift it's really great for people
of all ages some of it's simple some of
it gets more advanced you can also get
20
off a premium subscription by going to
brilliant.org
number file
you can go and have a look at the
website without a subscription of course
but make sure you use the slash number
file for the discount
thanks brilliant for supporting this
episode
[Music]
all right
it's a mouse